Ça va, Richard ?
Bonjour, c'est...
Vous allez me licencier ?
Pas du tout, Didier !
Oui, allô... Je veux parler d'un truc...
Bonjour, c'est...
Vous allez me licencier ?
Oui Didier, on va vous licencier.
Oh non...
Parce que c'est moi qui démissionne !
Non, je plaisantais ! Gardez-moi, s'il-vous-plaît !
J'ai contracté un crédit à la consommation pour un canapé convertible !
Ça va, c'est pas non plus hyper cher.
Bonjour, c'est...
Vous allez me licencier ?
Non Didier ! On va vous muter !
Juste là !
A Saint-Omer, La Capelle.
Je pourrais pas plutôt être licencié ?
Bonjour, c'est...
Vous allez me licencier ?
Je vous avoue qu'il y a un petit suspens.
Face: Vous restez... Pile: Vous partez.
Et hop là !
Face !
On recommence !
Mais pourquoi vous faites ça !?
Allez ! On va y arriver !
Bonjour, c'est...
Vous allez me licencier ?
Vous tombez bien, Didier. Oui, on va vous licencier. On doit faire des économies.
Mais si vous évitiez d'imprimer les portraits des employés et de faire du gâchis de papier et d'encre...
On en ferait peut-être des économies, non ?
Mais c'est vrai, ça !
Didier, vous remplacez Gérard.
Ouais !
Gérard, vous êtes licencié.
Vous faites une petite photo vite fait et puis vous m'imprimez ça.
Mais non mais c'est ça qu'il faut pas faire.
Faut pas imprimer justement. Ah mais oui !
Didier, vous me remplacez.
Ouais !
Après, l'avantage avec...
Vous êtes licenciés !
Vous avez pas le pouvoir de faire ça, hein ?
Ah bon ?
Il suffit pas d'accrocher des portraits au tableau ?
Bah... En... En vrai, si...
Non, pas du... Pas du tout !
Non, ça marche pas... C'est pas comme ça qu'on fait. Enlevez-les tout de suite, vite !
Bonjour, c'est...
Vous allez me licencier ?
Oui Didier, j'en suis désolé.
C'est la pire des choses qui pouvaient m'arriver.
Chéri !
Je te quitte.
C'est la pire des choses qui pouvaient m'arriver.
Monsieur Frizoti ?
J'ai pas une bonne nouvelle. Malheureusement, votre maman vient de décéder.
C'est vraiment la pire des choses qui pouvaient m'arriver.
Ça, bizarrement, ça me dérange pas plus que ça.
Vous allez me licencier ?
Oui.
Mais je... Je travailles même pas ici !
On vous embauche !
Oh cool !
Et maintenant, on vous licencie.
'Tin, ils sont forts !
Ils sont forts.
On avait commander une pizza, non ?
Bonjour, c'est...
Vous allez me licencier ?
Hé oui, Didier.
Enfin...
LE licencier !
Parce que c'est pas moi, là.
Si, si.
Non, non.
Oh que si.
Ils son fuertos.
Bonjour, c'est...
Vous allez me licencier ?
Je vous préviens, si vous me licencier, je dis à tout le monde que vous êtes ensemble !
A toute la boîte !
Joyeux anniversaire.
Vous êtes viré.